[Music]
hunter is with us in greenville south
carolina hi hunter how are you
um right now i'm nervous because i
didn't think that i would actually get
through today how are you guys well
we're honored to speak with you how can
we help
yeah
um so i come from a family where
financial literacy wasn't really taught
we didn't talk about money we saw
parents put everything on credit cards
live on debt paycheck paycheck um that
changed when my husband and i got
married we went through the baby steps
um we paid off all of our debt two years
ago and we're currently saving for a
house down payment right now good for
you um you broke the change yeah where'd
it go yeah yeah unfortunately my sisters
are all still kind of stuck
in that
living paycheck to paycheck living in
debt and we find ourselves constantly
bailing them out and even today one of
my sisters called me
in tears asking for money and um they're
in a really deep hole and so of course i
have this is the third time we've bailed
her out and given 1500 over the last
three months to some of my sisters to
build them out
um and so i'm just trying to find the
balance of like when's enough enough is
it okay to put stipulations when you're
giving money to family like hey i'm
gonna give you this but like i wanna i
wanna sit down and do a budget with you
or it's like that overstepping i don't
know that's kind of my question i'm
looking for advice and guidance how old
are you
um i'm 26.
how many sisters three
i have three sisters two older sisters
and one younger sister okay
um hunter i i'll let dave answer the the
back into this but
it sounds like you're giving money less
because they need it and more you feel
like you have to
whether that's from a place of guilt you
quote unquote got out or you just feel
like it's your job am i am i right
i would say that's true i definitely
come from like an emotionally
manipulative family i don't really have
too much to do with like my parents and
things like that too much anymore
um and i don't know i guess i feel a
sense of responsibility for them because
like i see where we were kind of let
down and i found a way out i guess maybe
um i don't know i just i don't want to
see them struggle
and yeah
nobody wants to see somebody they love
struggle and at the same time
um
you can't help her be in better shape by
running her miles for her
yeah you can help with a workout plan
you can call and check up on her and see
how her workouts are going you all can
run together but she won't lose weight
when you don't eat that's right you
can't run her miles for her so
my recommendation listening just and
this is not for everybody this is just
listening to you
is that you and your husband stop cut it
off and that may be an email that says
we're no longer going to support in this
way but right now you need to get okay
with you and you're not there yet and
giving
letting that money leave to try to help
you is different than i see a need i'm
going to go meet that need right now
you're trying to meet your own needs
right
and then dave you you've you've taught
me a lot about stipulation it's your
money to give right you can put over
stipulation on it you want to because
it's your money
you have absolutely zero moral or
spiritual obligation for a sibling who
is misbehaving
yeah none
i set you free right now
it's not your job yeah
it's not your job yeah
it's hard to watch
it's very hard to watch people you love
be stupid
yeah
they like just bought a house they just
bought a house and
like i invite like they came to me for
advice i'm making their budget to buy
the house and i was like look i really
don't think this is in y'all's budget
because before when we bailed them out
we did you know i said i thought
they went against your advice and bought
something they couldn't afford and then
last week they came to you for money
yeah well today they came to me for
money but yeah
did you give it to them today
um i did send her money today and i told
them i was like oh i want to sit down
with both of you guys this time because
like you can't do it on your own like
you and your husband have to be in on
this
and he doesn't even need to sit down so
he doesn't have one because you keep
giving money yeah she doesn't have a
need to sit down yeah
yeah that's true so
not because it's the right thing to do
morally
because you are a classic enabler
yeah you
enablers don't put stipulations on
giving a drunk a
drink okay
now there's nothing morally wrong with
giving the guy who says we'll work for
food money at the corner because he's in
a hard time that's fine
but if we wanted to love him better
we would stop take the time which takes
more time to love someone well
it's more inconvenient and we would walk
him over to mcdonald's and buy him a
meal
if he would go no
if he really will work for tell us tell
us what's going on he may just flip you
off and tell you to get off his corner
but um in which case you know i think we
found out the real deal right which it's
some of both when the guy's standing out
there with a sign and so
you want to love people that are hurting
well
uh but loving them well does require
stipulations it does require boundaries
not for you
and not because it's the law
but because
what is good for her
what you've been doing has not been good
for her
you've been financing her crazy butt
life
it's not been good for her you've been
giving a drunk a drink you've been
harming your sister
that makes
sense yeah oh no it definitely makes
sense
your lack of courage to say no or not
put stipulations on this because you
felt
somehow you felt better if you just gave
her money she would go away without any
kind of a conflict or without any kind
of her mother's manipulation come your
mother's manipulation coming out of your
sister's mouth directed at your forehead
uh you didn't want to deal with all that
and so you cheaped out and gave her
money
it's a make no mistake when you draw
this boundary she's going to be pissed
she's going to come run and bang up
against that boundary and see if it
holds yep and you are going to can't
believe you're doing this to us we hate
you oh you're miss goody two-shoe oh
you're rich you got it all figured out
yeah you forgot your raisin expect all
of that and the pain and that is first
what's wrong with you i can tell now
that you married him right you're gonna
hear all this bull crap redneck bull
crap i can hear it right now doesn't
mean it's wrong doesn't mean it's wrong
okay yeah yeah
i can say that because i know it well
personally okay so
uh
not not not as a not putting somebody
down not you anyway so anyway this is
what's gonna happen the same stuff that
you distance yourself from your parents
is what's gonna happen when you draw
this boundary now what you can do though
is just be loving and kind and gentle
and say i would love to help you
when you complete financial peace
university
and i get to see the budget that you two
are doing together if i can participate
in some of your getting out of debt
process and you're getting in control
we'll try to do that i am no longer
going to give you money without you
having done that though
or what john said is okay too
just to make sure you first get whole
and you're doing this from strength just
say you know what i would if i could but
i can't right now i don't feel good
about the way this is going i feel bad i
feel like i'm bringing you harm and i
just can't do it anymore i'm so sorry i
love you but i just can't give you money
yeah
and if she says well if you know if you
really love me you give me money well
listen if you have to buy your
relationship that's called prostitution
that's true it's not a real
relationship yeah and so it you know
that's that's the deal so if she puts a
boundary on you that says the only way
we have a relationship is money then we
know how things do it
so and after you get your house
you you save up for your house you get
it paid off i mean you get your down
payment ready to rock and roll then you
might be in a place to say okay let's
sit down and have this conversation but
you need to heal from the inside out too
yeah it's okay to say no and you really
really need to